we are back here uh with actor
extraordinaire but also uh bachelor
superfan toe for grace everybody i'm
happy to
i'm happy to say jessie asked me and i
am going to be the next bachelor
wow i can't i can't believe it um but
also the extraordinary host of the
bachelor jesse palmer is here thank you
so much for having me thank you praising
us pun intended with his presence
um okay what is your favorite part about
hosting the bachelor uh well it's way
less stressful being the host
than it is actually being the bachelor
because you don't have to worry about
dealing with all the drama
you don't have to deal with breaking
people's hearts
calling out the wrong name at rose
ceremonies like somebody once upon a
time dude
i don't know what's next not imagine
what it's like to be the bachelor i i
really can't jesse
like you know
do you think that we could even like ask
a bachelor because we do have another
surprise for topher we do yeah listen i
mean obviously i was the bachelor it was
a long time ago you were probably just a
kid when it happened but there is
someone i can think of who um
a certain mr clayton eckerd maybe
everybody yes the bachelor now
[Applause]
yeah jesse drew thinks it's a prank on
me this is actually just a prank on my
wife
well i was gonna say ashley grace greg
how are you doing that for you
i want to shout her out as well
oh man clayton just give us a give us a
hint man give us a hand
do you want me to you want me to wake
one time if if this happened or think
twice of another
i uh listen i i'm doing well overall i
heard you you said you hadn't seen the
women tell all uh buckle up for that one
i had to do that
to say the least are you very happy in
your life right now
i am a happy man yes i've learned a lot
of lessons and i'm better than i was
when i came in as a human being clayton
for you
having you know been a bachelor and now
that or you know being on both sides of
it i should say
what do you like best about
being in the driver's seat and what's
the worst thing about it
oh jesse alluded to it i'll start off i
always want to end on a good note so let
me start off with what was tough was the
uh
lack of control i had a little bit but
not nearly as much as kind of what i
thought at times and i had to be able to
sit back and just tell myself hey you
know roll with the punches do what you
can be your authentic self and
at the end of the day if you do that you
won't look back and have regrets even
though i made mistakes i mean so very
apparent as everyone's seen and i accept
full responsibility for those actions
but with that again i think the best
part about it is i've been able to grow
as an individual i think i had five
years of growth it packed into
two months and
for that i'm so very thankful i've built
so many great connections and for that
again it's like i'm just happy to have
been able to go through it i'd love to
ask
clayton
jesse and topher um
like as a woman if i could
like hear
your um deal breakers like what is one
thing you cannot live without a woman
what is one thing you can't live with a
woman clayton you start please
a sense of humor is right there up at
the top so i look for somebody that can
make me laugh on a daily basis uh and
someone that's a little weird i like
weirdness it just makes me like it's
unique and i it keeps me on my toes so
that's something i look for uh something
that frustrates me is uh it's kind of
just i think what everybody else would
say as far as uh someone who's
rude or impatient uh something along
those lines i think under be someone i
just want someone's understanding and
that's that's critical more than
anything else
okay good to know and
good to know for the last three ladies
jesse what about you what is like a
must-have and what's a deal bro i'm real
big on family values and it doesn't hurt
if you make great chocolate brownies
i think if um
a deal breaker for me would be
if you were inconsiderate i think for me
that that's a big one that would
probably be it for you you stole mine
dude i would actually i would i kind of
like the same thing as you yeah brownies
but i think respect for others and you
know
going on a date early on where
someone's really rude to the waiter and
i just thought like but she was being
really nice to me and i thought that's
that's not cool like this person is
actually serving us you know like
it was a great telltale sign yeah and a
must-have
um everything that ashley grace is
smart man
and jessie and clayton thank you so much
for embracing that so great with your
time and your presence and topher your
amazing show home economics is every
wednesday night at 9 30 on abc
congratulations it's a huge success and
i'm so happy for you because you deserve
everything good in your life and you
just put out the goods and you are good
and this was so good
[Music]